Und das war's für heute.
Das wird so werden, weil die eingehen natürlich mit dem entsprechenden Elan dran, Juhu Spielzeug, lass mal gucken, wie es wird. Stehen dem auch schon ein bisschen vielleicht offener gegenüber, aber irgendjemand anderes, älteres, die dann gerät, was auf einmal statt fünf irgendwie vor noch fünf Knöpfen vorne auf einmal noch so eine Zehnertastatur drauf hat. Das wird schon anders werden.
Irgendwas ist ja immer. Wenn ihr euch gerade fragt, worum geht es denn hier? Es geht hier um Digitalfunk und das hat einen ganz einfachen Grund, warum es heute um so ein Thema geht, denn ihr seid hier.
Blum, die zwei Sprechstunden.
Dieser Sound bedeutet, ihr seid im Chaos Radio angekommen. Da geht es heute um Digitalfunk. Wir wollen nämlich heute mal wissen, was mit den neuen Funkgeräten ist, die die Berliner Polizei so kriegen soll. Und da haben wir jetzt Detlef an Telefonen. Der ist nämlich Polizeibeamter in Berlin und kann ein Wörtchen mitreden. Hallo und guten Abend. Du hast so ein digitales Funkgerät schon mal in der Hand gehabt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das in der Hand hatte, wobei ihr redet, aber ich habe das, was in Berlin, im Testteil Charlottenburg-Spandau über Jahre schon im Testbetrieb war. Und zwar ist das ein T3-Gerät von Motorola. Nur mal größer als ein normales Mobilfunkgerät und auch nicht mit dieser Nokia-Systematik aufgebaut, ein bisschen anders. Und wurde nun, jetzt ist der Testbetrieb einmal abgeschaltet worden. Jetzt wird das Betrieb insgesamt in den Dienstbetrieb überführt. Und jetzt laufen analog und digital, sag ich mal, parallel.
Und heißt das ja, ihr habt in den Fahrzeugen beide Geräte oder wie?
Genau, nicht nur zwei Geräte, eigentlich drei Geräte, weil ja in den Fahrzeugen selbst ein eingebautes 4-Meter-Gerät ist, wer damit umgehen kann, weiß, dass das anders arbeitet als das Handgerät und obendrein dazu jetzt das T3-Gerät. Also zwei Mann, drei Funkgeräte. Es bleibt mitunter solche Blüken, dass da vier, fünf, sechs Kollegen an einem Einsatzort kommen, aber nicht miteinander funken können, weil unterschiedliche Standards verteilt sind.
Das heißt, die einen haben noch die Analogtechnik, die anderen nur digital?
Analog haben eigentlich alle. Aber gelegentlich hat eben einer dann sein analoges nicht mit, sondern ein Tetra. Und der kann mit keinem Fahrzeug und mit keinem anderen Fußgänger kommunizieren. Nur mit der Tetra-Zentrale.
Verstehe. Und die kann dann maximal noch auf analog rüber vermitteln oder wie?
Könnte dann bestenfalls zwei Hörer gleichzeitig in der Hand halten, genau. Denn die kann auch nicht von analog auf digital schalten. Das geht auch nicht.
Gibt da kein Geld wieder zwischen? Wie hat sich das denn ausgedacht?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste. Dass es zwischen diesem Analogen und diesem Digitalen irgendwas noch gibt.
Und wie sind denn so die Erfahrungen? Man hört ja mal wieder, dass es so ein bisschen kritisch ist mit der Reichweite in Gebäuden und so. Habt ihr da schon Erfahrungen?
Ja, aber im Gegensatz, also die mit der Reichweite in Gebäuden hat ja jedes Funkgerät seine Schwierigkeiten. Und wenn ein Autonormalfahrbraucher der Bürger wüsste, wie geordenerhaft schlecht die Reichweite der analogen Geräte ist, dann würde jeder Bürger ein Zehner extra geben, damit ich endlich einen vernünftigen kriege. Also der Spruch bitte wechseln Sie Ihren Standort, ich kann Sie nicht aufnehmen. Den hört man auch heute noch fast täglich. Weil das Analogenetz eben nicht flächendeckend zwischen den Häuserzeilen ist, sondern manchmal geht ein, zwei Meter nach links und nach rechts und dann hab ich wieder eine Verbindung.
Verstehe die Wellenthele. Und mit den Digitalen ist das da ähnlich oder fühlt sich das anders an?
Nein, war das ähnlich, aber da ist ein immenser Aufwand betrieben worden. Wann immer, wir sind aufgefordert worden, möglichst viel damit zu funken. Macht man natürlich nur dann, wenn man es sich leisten kann, wenn man nicht darauf angewiesen ist, dass es immer funktioniert. Aber sobald wir eine Fehlfunktion bemerkt haben, Standort, ich sage mal, Tarantin, Breitscheidplatz, Wurms vor dem Wasserklopf, Verbindungen hinter dem Wasserklopf Kleine, dann gab es dafür bei uns eine Dienststelle, die da händesehend darauf gewartet hat, dass solche Meldungen gekommen sind. Und die sind dann ganz gezielt diese Funklöcher ausgemerzt worden.
Okay, das hat schon systematisch im Testbetrieb versucht worden?
Das ist auf den Westteil beschränkt gewesen, weil man versucht hat, mit welchem Aufwand das da realisierbar ist und ob das dann letzten Endes auch geht. Und die sind dann massenhaft dann auch tatsächlich mit diesen Informationen überschwemmt worden. Später dann war die nächste Stufe dann mit die Verbindungsqualität in Gebäuden. Und wenn man so einen 100 Jahre alten, ich vergleiche das mit dem Amtsgericht oder mit dem Kriminalgericht, in so einem Gebäude wieder Winkel findet und sagt, hier habe ich keinen Kontakt, dann können die irgendwo gegensteuern und dann kriegt man eben doch deutlich die digitale Verbindung.
Also du bist sozusagen optimistisch, dass es mit dem Digitalfunk am Ende besser wird?
Es wird wesentlich besser. Für mich, ich weiß nicht, die Feuerwehr hat nicht ein Problem, vorhin hat ein Kollege von der Feuerwehr gesprochen, der sagte, er weiß nicht, worum die das kriegen. Ich habe so oft in meinem täglichen Dienst damit zu tun oder beschäftige andere Leute damit zu tun, für mich irgendwo anzurufen. Ich sage eine Telefonnummer durch und sage, bitte rufen Sie dort an und fragen Sie ob. Zum Beispiel. Und das kann ich mit dem Teil selber, selbst eine Funkbeziehung, also mit dem Mobilfunk kann ich damit einwählen. Wer und wo da irgendwas mit schreibt und mit liest, ist mir in dem Sinne eigentlich auch völlig schnuppel, weil er immer einen dienstlichen Bezug hat, was ich damit telefoniere. Das kann ich also rechtfertigen. Wenn ich mich mal rechtfertigen müsste, ist noch nicht vorgekommen. Aber das vereinfacht viele Sachen, wenn ich direkt mit den Leuten sprechen kann, von denen ich was will.
Das heißt also, du erwartest schon, dass es im normalen Dienstalter einfach einfacher wird?
Hat schon, ist ja schon. Wir haben ja über Jahre diesen Testbetrieb und wir haben auch noch diese alten Tetra-Teile, die irgendwann wieder abgeschaltet werden, wenn es dann diese Satzgeräte gibt, die da jetzt in Mitte eingeführt worden sind.
Wie ist denn da jetzt so der Einführungszeitplan? Also wie schnell wird das gehen in Berlin?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Also wird jetzt erst mal sukzessive in Mitte eingeführt und dann...
Das ist die offizielle Pressemeldung, dass die ersten 1000 Geräte jetzt ausgeliefert werden sollen. Und irgendeiner hat mal feierlich das erste Gerät überreicht.
Das lassen sich ja immer nicht entgehen.
Ja genau, aber das ist ja beim Wachtmeister nicht angekommen. Der Wachtmeister hat die Zwei-Meter-Technik. Und die Zwei-Meter-Technik, das Handfunkgerät ist 30 Jahre alt. So alt sind fast alle, oder 35 jetzt inzwischen, so alt sind fast alle Geräte und halb so alt sind alle Akkus. Also nur nach dem Motto, warum brauchen wir was Neues, wenn ich den Leuten sage, ich habe immer ein Reserveakku mit, weil ich nie weiß, wie lange hält mein Akku.
Das heißt, der hält nicht einen Tag durch, oder wie?
Um Gottes Willen, mal hatte ich einen der ältesten Tag, aber ich hab auch mal eine der ältesten Stunde. Oder der kommt voll geladen aus dem Ladegerät, die dann automatisch geht und entladen. Da sind immer riesen Batterien, muss ich vorstellen. Ich mache vielleicht mit, sagen wir mal, mit einer Nachtschicht von 30 Mann. Der hat ständig 50 Akkus zum Laden und Entladen. Und jeder, der kommt, reinkommt und genau weiß, ich hab schon ein paar Mal gefunkt, der schmeißt einen halb vollen oder ich weiß nicht, wie viel noch drin vollen Akku, renne in den Ladenschacht und nimmst den vollen wieder raus. Wie lange der hält, weiß er aber nicht. Also es ist schon diverse Male. Man kann dann zwar noch empfangen, wenn der Akku fast leer ist, aber man kann nicht mehr senden. Jeder, der das Lied kennt, wird dann wissen, wie oft ihr es nicht aufnehmen könnt, bitte kommen Sie überdrehen. Und dann hol ich mein Privat-Handy raus und sage, nur manchmal ist es ja auch wichtig, dass man ne Meldung los wird, dass irgendetwas nicht so schlimm ist, wie gedacht. Dass sich irgendetwas nicht bestätigt hat. Na ja, dafür nehme ich dann mein Privat-Handy.
Und wie ist das? Habt ihr da in dem Feldversuch jetzt auch schon die Datendienste ausprobiert, so für Halteabfragen und ähnliche Dinge?
Das funktioniert ja sowieso über Draht bei uns. Also, die mache ich ja nicht selber. Ich rufe irgendwo an, wo ich die Auskünfte kriege.
Verstehe, das heißt, das macht ihr noch nicht über das Tetra-System?
Das würde ich auch nicht machen wollen. Dafür ist die Tastatur für so unpraktisch. Also machen wir uns nichts vor. Wir sind ja, wenn ich da bin, ich bin ja kein SMS-Künstler. Mein Telefon hab ich in der Hand und meine Umgebung muss ich wahrnehmen. Wenn ich dann anfangen soll auf dieser Tastatur, die doppelt, ich sag mal, bei der Motorola ist die doppelt so groß wie wenn, eine Telefon-Tastatur.
Also das heißt, du würdest aber die neuen Funkgeräte sozusagen nur deswegen gut finden, weil sie halt zuverlässiger funken, aber sozusagen diese Datendienste wären dir eigentlich egal, weil das halt sozusagen zu viel wäre.
Noch sind sie mir egal. Wenn ich denn in meinem übernächsten Funkwagen, in dem Auslieferungszustand 2020 tatsächlich auch eine mobile Schreibmaschine habe, dann brauche ich natürlich eine zuverlässige Datenverbindung in meiner Abfragesysteme.
Das heißt, du würdest das schon gut finden, wenn sie irgendwie über das T-Dra dann die Fahndungsbilder dann auf einem Laptop in einen Streifenwagen irgendwie senden.
Das wird mit Sicherheit nicht gehen. Natürlich gibt es von vielen Personen, die mal erkennungsdienstlich behandelt wurden, zum Beispiel Bilder, die ich abfragen kann, wenn ich an meinem Dienst PC sitze.
Aber kannst du halt nicht unterwegs.
So etwas kann ich alles nicht vor Ort machen. Das ist also viel zu aufwendig. Das ist keine rollende Büro. Ich brauche eine mobile Schreibmaschine, wo ich Sachverhalte die Wahrnehmung schnell zu Papier bringen kann oder überhaupt nur Notizen zu machen. Aber die richtige Vorgangsfertigung, was Hand und Fuß haben muss, was zum Schluss beim Richter liegt, das kann ich nicht auf der Straße machen. Und dann auch nebenbei gucken, ob mir jemand über die Schulter schaut. Machen wir uns das nicht vor. Das sind ja dann alles hochsensive Daten. Ich müsste in einem halb abgedunkelten Fahrzeug sitzen und die Zugriff von fremden Leuten müsste ich wieder ausschließen können. Guckt einer rein und sagt, was macht der denn? Es geht alles nicht.
Ich fürchte, die Leute, die das geplant haben, machen sich solche Gedanken nicht.
Doch, das machen die. Zumindest, was bei uns die Datensicherheit angeht.
Zumindest so was wie Halterabfrage überfunktet, hat man ständig gelesen überall als das neue Feature. Ja, jetzt gibt es auch Datendaste und so.
Natürlich kann ich die Halterabfrage überfunkt machen. Theoretisch, aber praktisch. Wenn ich heute eine Halterabfrage mache, ruf ich an bei der Fahndungsstelle und sage, ich brauche zudem und dem Fahrzeug folgende Auskünfte. Und der sieht an meiner Nummer, dass das ein Tetra ist und kann mir die Auskünfte geben. Könnte ja jeder Vollidioter anrufen und den Nachbarn abfragen oder was. Wenn die Nummer erstmal bekannt ist. Das ist ja eine Nummer, die man vom öffentlichen Apparat auch anwählen könnte, wenn man sie dann wüsste.
Okay, sagen Sie jetzt nicht...
Da sitzt ja jemand am Telefon an seinem Rechner und der macht nichts anderes als den ganzen Tag Fahndungsabfragen, weil den ganzen Tag bei ihrem Kollegen sagen, ich brauche zu dem Fahrzeug diese Nummer. Und es geht bei dem auch am schnellsten. Der antwortet mir nicht und sagt mir, was ich hören will.
Okay, also Digitalfunk quasi nur zum Funken, der Rest wird nachher von Menschen gemacht. Noch eine Frage an Detlef?
Ich interessiere mich bloß dafür, wie oft es passiert, dass man zu irgendeinem, keine Ahnung was passiert, irgendein Tatort kommt und da steht schon die Presse.
Mehrfach. Also und richtig übel, wo ich sage, mein lieber Herr Gesangverein, es wird höchste Zeit, dass man da was vorschiebt. Kann ich eine Geschichte aus dem wahren Leben erzählen? Ein Wohnungsbrand mit mehreren Toten. Ich bin der erste Funkwanger am Ort gewesen und hab dann meine Telefonnummer durchgegeben und ihr sagt ab jetzt nur noch über diese Nummer, weil ich wusste draußen die Feuerwehr Riesen aufgebohrt und noch bevor mich mein Vorgesetzter anrufen konnte, klingelt mein Telefon, stellt sich jemand vor, guten Tag, ich bin der und der und wie du bist denn aus da oben? Dann hab ich gefragt und der hat sich mit dem Namen des Abschnittsleiters vorgestellt, mit dem Nachnamen. Dann hab ich gesagt, wie heißen Sie denn mit Vornamen? Dann hat er einen Vornamen genannt und dann hab ich gesagt, tut mir leid für Sie, mein Abschnittsleiter heißt anders. Die haben also sowieso alles mitgehört und waren schneller als die Dienststelle mich anzurufen. Ja und das war diejenige Sache, die war ja nicht zu übersehen. Ein brennendes Hochhaus, sag ich mal, das sieht man ja. Mit Auswirkungen auf den Straßenverkehr, am hellerlichten Tare, das kann man ja noch verstehen. Aber ich hab auch schon einen Suizid gehabt, Nacht um drei, wo an allen Türen Kollegen standen, im Innenhof, ohne jede Außenwirkung und plötzlich, bevor die Kriminalpolizei da war, von Balkons mit glücklich geschlossen worden.
Das heißt, du erwartest dir von dem digitalen Funk und der Verschlüsselung dann auch so ein bisschen Diskretion in der Richtung?
Na ja, Diskretion, ich sag mal, die Presse, die sich in Hubschrauber reinsetzt, um einen Verkehrsunfall zu fotografieren, der von Leuten, die eigentlich zum Retten und Bergen und zum Helfen da sind, die damit beschäftigt sind, irgendwelche Planen hochzuhalten, sind es schon makaber genug. Die werden also immer Wege finden. Aber es macht natürlich viele Sachen sicher. Und obendrein kann mir auch nicht jemand dazwischen sprechen. Was ich zum Beispiel mit dem Tetra noch nie beobachtet habe, aber beim Analog-Funk gang und gäbe ist, dass funkferngesteuerte Ampeln den Verkehr stören. Die Protokollstrecken von Tegel, Intrigierungen, Zürtel, durch die halbe Stadt, die können ja zentral geschaltet werden. Ampelausfall ist gar nicht. Die schalten zwei Minuten bevor die Kolonne kommt alle Ampeln aus, so wie sie sie brauchen, und zwei Minuten später wieder ein. Und wenn ich das auf einer Hauptverkehrsstraße mache, staut sich natürlich in fünf Minuten wat.
Und dann, wenn das passiert, dann stört das den Analogfunk?
Nein, grundsätzlich, die Ampel kommuniziert ständig mit der Verkehrsleitzentrale. Die wissen also immer den Ampelzustand, wie er gerade schaltet. Und können da eingreifen. Also ein hochmodernes System.
Also per Funk oder?
Auf welcher Basis die das schalten, weiß ich nicht, aber es ist alles funkgesteuert.
Und dann, dass die Signale von den Ampeln stören, das analoge Funkgerät, aber das geht nicht. Aber nur mit den Analogen, also mit digitalen Geräten funktioniert das dann?
Im digitalen funktioniert das, genau.
Die haben auch eine andere Frequenz.
Wenn ich tatsächlich so einen ungünstigen Standort habe, muss ich mein großes Funkgerät ausmachen, weil es nur am Knarren ist.
Einblicke ins Berliner Polizeileben von Detlef, vielen Dank dafür. Ihr seid hier nämlich im Chaos Radio auf Fritz, wo es um Digitalfunk heute geht. Wir haben jetzt schon gelernt, wie digital funktioniert, dass die Behörden ihn bekommen sollen und dass es manche Leute gibt, die sagen, ja das ist ganz cool und manche, die sagen, naja eigentlich brauchen wir es nicht so richtig. Ich wäre jetzt für eine Runde Musik, was sagt ihr? Ich habe ja in der Vorbereitung dieser Sendung natürlich gedacht, der Chaos Radio, Chaos Computer Club, da muss er Musik aus dem Netz machen, habe auch ein bisschen rumgefragt im Chat, war da irgendwie kaum mal am Start. Also anscheinend ist Netzmusik noch gar nicht so verbreitet, den kreisen, wie ich das dachte, deswegen möchte ich euch das präsentieren und mitbringen. Jetzt gibt es Professor Klick, total großartig, Plastic and Flashing Lights.
Und bald wieder.
Der außergewöhnliche und supergeniale Professor Klick mit Plastic and Flashing Lights, der auch im Chat auf große Zustimmung gestoßen ist. Im Chat ist auch noch die Frage aufgetaucht, hey, wenn sich GSM und Tetrafunk so ähneln, warum nennt man da nicht einfach die GSM Zellen zum Tetrafunken?
Der wesentliche Grund ist die Rufaufbauzeit. Es gab ja den Vorschlag, als es um diesen digitalen Behördenfunk ging, einfach zu sagen, okay, wir bohren einfach die GSM Netze ein bisschen auf, also die normalen Mobilfunknetze bohren die ein bisschen auf, so dass man darüber halbwegs gesichert Behördenkommunikation abwickeln kann. Und das Problem war, dass sie die Rufaufbauzeiten, also die Zeit, wo wenn du auf die Taste drückst, bis das auf der anderen Seite blieb macht, dass sie die nicht irgendwie unter vier Sekunden bekommen haben. So und die Anforderung in der Ausschreibung war, halt irgendwie zu sagen, halbe Sekunde oder weniger. So sollte halt das sein, weil wenn da so ein Feuerwehrmann im brennenden Haus steht oder so ein Polizist irgendwie...
Die Verbindung wird gehalten.
Genau. Der eine Grund, der andere Grund ist, dass man dann natürlich Kapazitäten im GSM-Netz garantieren müsste, die auch unter extremen Bedingungen immer zur Verfügung stehen. Und dafür ist das GSM-Netz schlicht nicht gebaut. Die Mobilfunknetze sind halt, wenn der Strom ausfällt, dann laufen die vielleicht maximal noch sechs Stunden weiter. Und so die Tetranetze, Tetranetze wird halt dafür aufgebaut, sehr viel länger auch noch zu funktionieren. Selbst wenn der Strom weg ist, sind halt Akkus drin und Generatoren.
Okay, also im Prinzip ist es eine ähnliche Technologie, aber es macht also sagen technisch nicht so gleich, dass man es einfach zusammenwerfen könnte. Genau. Bevor wir jetzt tatsächlich dann aber zum GSM-Netz kommen, wollte ich noch kurz Matthias dran nehmen. Matthias hat nämlich den Morse-Code vielleicht gelöst, der am Anfang der Sendung gespielt wurde. Habt ihr den noch mal kurz da?
Oh nein, wo ist er? Extra Punkte. Gibt auch noch Eiszomate.
Großartig. Matthias, was war das für ein Morse-Code?
Also ich meine, dass das SOS war.
Falsch.
Du hast verloren.
Also du kriegst Bonus-Kunden, Kürpunkte für Morse-Code vorsingen und überhaupt anrufen, weil du bist der Erste, der das versucht hat.
Genau, aber es war leider nicht so trivial.
Können wir noch mal hören?
Wir spielen nochmal ab.
Ja, ihr habt noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit, um das zu versuchen zu lösen.
Amateur-Funker sind irgendwie am Aussterben, oder? Besonders solche, die morsen können.
Oder die gucken noch Fußball, oder ist Fußball fertig?
Also wenn ich so sehe, was da... Das ist das Fernsehprogramm, wo vorhin noch Fußball war. Man muss ja immer informiert bleiben. Okay, Matthias, das war es leider nicht. Trotzdem danke für den Anruf.
Also das Fernsehprogramm, Matthias, läuft ja nämlich so ein bisschen um einen Spim-Folder.
Ja, das ist natürlich alles den Recherchezwecken. Gut, kommen wir doch nun zu etwas völlig Anderem. GSM. Genau, weil also Digitalfunk, um das es heute geht, ist zum einen dieser Behördenfunk, über den wir jetzt schon die ganze Zeit geredet haben, zum anderen aber auch das Stinknormale-Handynetz, was ja wirklich alle kennen, die vor den Radiogeräten sitzen. Das funktioniert auch so. Kann man damit auch Spaß haben?
Klar, also so ein GSM-Netz gibt es ja schon seit 1996, glaube ich. Korrigiert mich ungefähr, so 1996 wurden die ersten D-Netze tatsächlich installiert und der Vorteil von wie gesagt Digitalfunk wurde da auch relativ schnell deutlich. Man konnte Geräte kleiner und billiger bauen, man konnte sehr viel mehr Benutzer auf der gleichen Menge Frequenzen unterbringen. Das war ja auch so ein wesentlicher Punkt, dass man halt also, vorher gab es halt dieses C-Netz, also diese analogen Mobilfunksysteme, da konnte man halt auch nicht so richtig doll viele Benutzer mit gleichzeitig bedienen, weil die doch immer einen Funkkanal brauchten pro Gespräch. Und diese Funkkanäle gab es halt nicht so besonders viele, deswegen war da halt irgendwann Schluss, gab auch kein SMS und irgendwie die Benachrichtigung, dass jetzt zwar davon Anrufbeantworter sind, diese ganzen Dinge, die gab es halt alle nicht so richtig. Das war halt alles sehr analog und das klang halt auch so ein bisschen wie Funk, also muss man sagen, so die Gesprächsqualität war etwas räudig. Die Geräte waren so groß wie Briketts und hatten auch ungefähr dasselbe Gewicht und das hat sich dann halt alles geändert mit dem Aufkommen vom D-Netz. Im Wesentlichen ist das GSM-Protokoll Ende der 80er, Anfang der 90er spezifiziert worden. Also es hat schon doch ziemlich alt und gut abgehangen und wie immer bei solchen Technologien ist es so, dass es eine Weile dauert, bis die so in das Feld kommen, wo man als Hobbyist damit auch was anfangen kann, also damit halt selber rumspielen kann und bei GSM ist es jetzt mittlerweile so weit, dass wir so in diesen Bereich kommen. Das heißt, dass es gibt jetzt eine ganze Menge interessante Projekte, zum Beispiel sich eigene GSM-Basis-Stationen zu bauen.
Also wir machen unser eigenes GSM-Netz.
Genau.
Also sprich, es gibt ja in Zukunft Telekom, wo davon O2 und E+, und das C-Netz, das TCC-Netz.
Genau, wir könnten mal wieder ein C-Netz machen, ja das wäre doch tatsächlich mal irgendwie eine Option. Genau. Also die Idee dabei ist halt folgende, die Technologie ist mittlerweile so gut verstanden und nach heutigen Maßstäben einfach, dass man in der Lage ist, sie selber zu bauen. Da kannst du vielleicht noch ein bisschen was zu erzählen.
Ja, vor allem offen standardisiert, was natürlich ein großer Vorteil ist bei der Entwicklung von Software in der Richtung. Da hat in dem Bereich Harald Welter aus unserem Club bei eBay eine BTS erstanden, eine BS11 Abis von Sie und...
Ein was?
Er hat eine BTS, eine Base Transceiver Station. Das sind die Dinger, die überall auf den Dächern rumstehen mit den lustigen Antennen.
Denkt an ein Modem.
Genau, denkt an ein Modem, die uns das Netz machen, also sprich die Sender und Empfänger.
Das sind diese großen Masken auf den Häusern, wo die sich viele Boxen haben. Das ist eine von diesen Boxen oder was?
Genau, also so ein Ding wie sie da auf den Dächern sind. Das ist halt eine große graue Kiste, wiegt ungefähr 30 Kilo, also ist ein bisschen zu schwer. Die Geräte sind halt ein bisschen älter, also die sind halt nicht umsonst jetzt auf eBay gewesen, weil sie halt überall abgeschraubt wurden, wo sie halt durch Neuere ersetzt wurden. Das ist halt so eines dieser Projekte, denn so ein Ding einfach mal zu nehmen und zu gucken, wie bekommt man die dazu, dass man sein Telefon darauf einbuchen kann.
Also das wäre dann quasi eine Funkzelle.
Genau, das sind eine Funkzelle.
So ein bisschen mehr als nur eine davon gefunden.
Genau, es gibt halt ein paar mehr davon. Also es ist halt nicht so, dass es nur eine gibt.
Okay, das hört sich total spannend an. Und ich würde deswegen sagen, wir hören jetzt oft drüber zu reden.
Und machen Nachrichten.
Cliffhanger und so und machen Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und danach werden wir darüber reden, wie wir unser ganz eigenes GM-Netz aufbauen. Ich bin schon sehr gespannt.
Tja, und das haben sie jetzt davon. Das Berlin Festival. Laute neue, aber vor allem lauter neue Musik live auf dem Flughafen Tempelhof. Mit Bonaparte. Jose González, Dendemann und The Rhytles. Mit den Junior Boys Who Made Who, The Killians und Deichkid. Und das sind längst noch nicht alle. Das Berlin-Festival. Am 7. und 8. August auf dem Flughafen Templo, mitten in Berlin. Karten gibt's überall, wo's Karten gibt und mehr Infos fritz.de. Das Berlin-Festival. Neue Musik live von der Open Airport.
Fritz Info.
Nachrichten. Mit Liane Grus.
Im Berliner Kanzleramt wird immer noch über die Zukunft des Opel Konzerns beraten. Die Bundesregierung will bei den Verhandlungen eine Überbrückungsfinanzierung für den Autobauer beschließen. Außerdem soll geklärt werden, wie Opel aus der drohenden Insolvenz von General Motors herausgehalten werden kann. Die drei Investoren Fiat, Magna und Ripplewood stellen noch einmal ihre Konzepte für eine Übernahme des Konzerns vor. Mit einer Festlegung auf einen der Interessenten ist nach Einschätzung von Regierungssprecher Wilhelm aber nicht zu rechnen. Die Streiks in den kommunalen Kindertagesstätten gehen weiter. Nach Gesprächen mit den Arbeitgebern in Berlin erklärte die Gewerkschaft Verdi, die Tarifverhandlungen für die rund 220.000 Beschäftigten für vorerst gescheitert. Der kommunale Arbeitgeberverband hatte ein Angebot zum Gesundheitsschutz vorgelegt, das sowohl Verdi als auch die GEW als nicht akzeptabel zurückwiesen. Heute beteiligten sich bundesweit rund 15.000 Beschäftigte an dem Ausstand in Kindergärten, Horten, Jugendzentren und Beratungsstellen. In Berlin hat es bei den Mathe-Prüfungen für den mittleren Schulabschluss heute erneut eine Panne gegeben. Wir im letzten Jahr kursierten wieder Prüfungsaufgaben im Internet. Allerdings waren es diesmal die falschen. Ein Sprecher vom Bildungssenat sagte, jemand habe die Aufgaben vom letzten Jahr mit einem neuen Deckblatt ins Netz gestellt. Die aktuellen Aufgaben sollen aber nicht durchgesickert sein. Wegen einer solchen Panne mussten letztes Jahr 28.000 Berliner Zehntklässler die Mathe-Prüfung wiederholen. Sport! Der FC Barcelona hat die Champions League gewonnen. In Rom besiegte der spanische Fußballmeister, äh, Entschuldigung, der spanische Fußballmeister Manchester United mit 2 zu 0. Barcelona holte damit als erste spanische Meisterschaft den Dreiersieg aus Meisterschaft, spanischem Pokal und dem Champions League Titel. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Potsdam-Cottbus, Angermünde 12 Grad, Frankfurt in Europin 13 und Bittenberg 14 und auch in Berlin 14 Grad. Es gibt noch ein paar Schauer am Abend. Es kann windig draußen sein. Bei Temperaturen zwischen 11 und 7 Grad. Tagsüber dann kommt die Sonne zwar raus, aber auch Wolken und etwas Regen sind wieder mit dabei bei 18 Grad. A10 westlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreikafelland zwischen Potsdam Nord und Spandau. Das ist ein defekter LKW. Hier ist die linke Spur gesperrt. Und die A24 Berlin Richtung Hamburg zwischen Dreikafelland und Dreikwitzstock Dossel. Da fährt ein Schwertransport. Hier kommt ihr nicht vorbei. Ansonsten Reutz, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2 dann Fritz rund um Spanberg.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Mit Markus Richter, Frank Krieger, Björn Heller und Andreas Bug, der immer verschwunden ist, wenn die Nachrichten kommen, im Chaosradio, was heute um Digitalfunk geht. Und Digitalfunk ist das, wo man jetzt denkt, was soll denn das sein? Aber das ist das, was wir ganz viel verwenden, zum Beispiel Mobilfunk auch. Und Mobilfunk ist so alt und so gut abgehangen, wie die Kollegen vom CCC gesagt haben, dass man sich das vielleicht sogar schon selber bauen kann.
Genau, die Idee dabei ist einfach, diese Telefon haben in der Tasche, die kosten nichts mehr. Wir haben ganze Schubladenfeuer von unseren alten Telefonen, da weiß auch niemand mehr, wo man damit hin soll. Und eigentlich wollen wir zumindest auf unseren Veranstaltungen und ähnlichen Gelegenheiten ein eigenes GSM Netz haben. Das ist mittlerweile im Rahmen des Möglichen und da gibt es halt mehrere Varianten dahin zu kommen. So ein GSM Netz besteht halt aus den Basisstationen, das sind also die Dinger, die auf den Dächern sind. Und dahinter braucht man dann auch so ein paar andere Komponenten, also die dann da machen, dass man das Funksignal, was auf der Basisstation ankommt, dass es auf den Draht geleitet wird, also umgewandelt wird, in die Vermittlungsstelle geht und mit den anderen Telefonen, die möglicherweise auf einer anderen Basisstation sind, verbunden wird.
Und ihr habt jetzt als Gerät erst mal nur dieses Funkding?
Genau, erst ist halt erst mal nur die Basisstation so. Und der Rest ist eigentlich nur Software. Software, wie wir wissen, gibt es halt mittlerweile ja im Open Source und solchen Dingen. Und da können halt viele Leute dran mitmachen, da muss man nicht im Moment Geld für bezahlen. Und das ist das, was gerade läuft. Also da gibt es halt so ein, ein Projekt ist halt zum Beispiel diese... Genau, OpenBSC. Der BSC steht für Base Station Controller. Das ist halt ein Stück Software, was nichts weiter macht als mit diesen Funksystemen, also den Base Stations, die auf den Dächern sind, zu reden und denen zu sagen, was sie zu machen haben. Und mit denen, die halt, wenn da so ein Anruf reinkommt, wissen, hier kommt jetzt ein Datenstrom, der sieht aus wie ein Anruf. Und mit dem Anruf müssen wir mal verarbeiten und weiterleiten und daraus halt eine Vermittlung, also daraus könnte ein Gespräch werden, ist halt so die Aufgabe, die dann wiederum hinter dem Base Station Controller, im sogenannten MSC, im Mobile Switching Center angesiedelt ist. Und da gibt es halt noch so ein paar Komponenten, die halt so Netz machen.
Das heißt, da gibt es irgendwie diese Base Station, wo man quasi die Handys sich einbuchen könnten und müsst jetzt dieses, hoffentlich, wenn ihr seid, dabei, dieses Open BSC Projekt, das ist auch schon mal ganz ausführlich besprochen worden, im Chaos Radio Express und zwar mit der Nummer 120, hatte ich, glaube ich, wenn ihr das mal ganz ausführlich hören wollt, dann geht auf chaosradio.de. Dort gibt es nämlich die ganze Folge zum Runterladen. Und wie weit seid ihr denn jetzt? Also kann man schon oder ist es noch eher so theoretisch?
Ja, aktuell ist es halt schon möglich, irgendwie Handys einzubuchen, Handys untereinander sprechen zu lassen, also sprich einen Rufaufbau. Einer von der Uni, ich hab das letztens auf der Mailing-Liste gelesen, hat schon geschafft, irgendwie das Ganze per VoIP irgendwie ins Telefonnetz zu routen. Das heißt, man hat irgendwie schon so einen Grundstein, das ganze Ding produktiver einzusetzen. SMS, wie gesagt, sind auch möglich. Problemlos aktuell ist das halt ein bisschen so mehr Hacker-Gefrickel. Also sprich Konsolen basiert irgendwie nicht click und nicht für den normalen Hausgebrauch. Allerdings in die Richtung vermute ich mal, wird es auch irgendwann mal gehen. Das heißt, Hardware ist da, Hardware, die man halt nur braucht, irgendwie die BTS, hat man da, dann kriegt man irgendwie so eine PC-Einstellkarte für einen PC für 300 Euro und man hat irgendwie sein ganzes Setup für GSM fertig, kann sich das ins Zimmer stellen.
Was ist insgesamt 300 Euro für einen Kram?
Also die BTS irgendwie, die Verkauf der Harald Welte. Da müsste man ihn ja mal fragen, so 300 Euro ist so der Richtwert für die BTS plus halt irgendwie 300 Euro irgendwie die Einsteckkarte für den Rechner, PCI. Und dann ist man so bei 600 Euro, das schon sehr billig ist und kann dann schon anfangen mit der Software, die ja gratis ist, sein eigenes GSM Netz zu starten.
Bevor wir da hinkommen, was wir damit machen, würde ich euch gerne eine ganz praktische Frage weiterreichen. Und zwar von Aline.
Ja genau, hallo. Und zwar ist mir das schon ein paar Mal passiert, dass ich aufgelegt habe, also mit meinem Mobiltelefon telefoniert habe und danach hat es, als ich mich aufgelegt habe, hat es ganz hoch gefiept. Also ich kann es gar nicht nachmachen. Also wirklich sehr hoch.
Denn Telefon.
Genau und das waren irgendwie so komische Geräusche, die ich so von meinem Telefon nicht kenne. Und da wollte ich mal fragen, ob ihr wisst, woher das kommt oder ob es vielleicht abgehört wird oder ob man das überhaupt erkennen könnte, wenn es abgehört wird oder so.
Also das klingt nach Telefon kaputt.
Ja, eindeutig das ist. Also wenn du abgehört wirst, merkst du in der Regel nichts davon. Und wenn du was merkst, weil zum Beispiel mehrere Geheimdienste dich gleichzeitig abhören und die Anlage nicht darauf ausgelegt ist, dann passieren dann so Sachen wie das Verbindung abbrechen oder du Leute dran hast, mit denen du gar nicht reden wolltest. Aber so ein Piepen nach dem Auflegen klingt nach Defekten. Telefon wegwerfen, neues kaufen.
Schön, dass es manchmal so einfach ist. Da hört keiner mit. Viel Spaß mit deinem Telefon. Vielleicht doch mal ein neues kaufen. Was ich auch noch sagen wollte, was gar nicht mit dem Thema zu tun hat, aber mit dem Chaos Computer Club ist, dass noch 383 Leute fehlen für die Netzsperren-Petition dagegen. Und es gibt Stimmen hier im Studio und im Chat, die sagen, das muss doch bis 23.55 Uhr zu schaffen sein.
Genau, klickt doch mal ein bisschen schneller.
Die fehlen an den 100.000 und die Petition läuft auch nur noch sehr sehr kurze Zeit. Wie viel genau, bis eins?
Die Petition läuft noch bis 16. Juni, oder?
16. Juni? Es läuft noch länger.
Es geht um den symbolischen Wert. Eigentlich wollte man diese 100.000 für heute Formattag fertig kriegen, wo es eine offizielle Anhörung im Bundestag gab. Juni. Und wir wollen das wahrscheinlich heute noch schaffen. Dann könnte man dann auf die 150 gehen. Und ich weiß nicht, was das nächste Ziel dann ist. Also falls ihr zu einem historischen Moment mithelfen wollt, jetzt eine gute Idee. ePetitionenBundestag.de Wobei ich ja auch gehört habe, dass der gar nicht sicher sein soll als Server. Na gut, andere Geschichte. Wir sind gerade bei GSM.
Sie hatten vorhin zwar verabtät.
GSM, da hab ich auch gleich noch einen Disclaimer. Selbstverständlich probieren wir solche Sachen nur mit einer drahtgebundenen Verbindung aus und funken nicht etwa illegal durch die Gegend.
Feridelscher Käfig.
Es ist ja denn, wir haben gerade eine Lizenz zum Beispiel auf den Veranstaltungen. Das ist so, dass wir uns, um so was auszuprobieren, also halt mit so einer Basisstation zu funken, braucht man eine Testlizenz von der Regulierungsbehörde. Die holen wir uns halt für unsere Veranstaltungen. Die bekommt man auch, wenn man sagt, okay, wir haben hier halt unsere...
Ist sowas teurer?
Kostet so 180 Euro für 30 Tage in dem Dreh.
Ja, also ist halt durchaus bezahlbar für so eine Veranstaltung. Kein Problem.
Okay, aber wichtige Informationen sagen, wenn ich jetzt sage, geil, das will ich auch, gehe ich nicht hin, kaufe mir so ein Ding und fange an, sondern...
Genau, also du brauchst eine Testlizenz oder also was halt geht, aber...
Das Zimmer mit Kupfer trapezieren.
Genau. Oder du hast halt einen Stahlbetonkeller, aus dem ohnehin kein Signal rausdringt. Also wichtig ist halt, dass du alles unternimmst, dass niemand gestört wird und das Netz auch nicht gestört wird. Also ist dann halt, also ist halt auch kein Schatz so.
Die verstehen da auch keinen Spaß.
Was passiert dann?
Na die kommen halt. Also die kommen dich dann halt jagen.
Und bei GSM Netzen, also erstens die Operator sehen es, wenn ihre Netze gestört werden. Das heißt, wenn du auf einer Frequenz sendest, wo irgendjemand anders sendet, dann gibt es da halt Probleme und das merken die und zwar sofort. Und dann können sie auch messen und sehen, dass dann ein Träger ist, der nicht hingehört und dann fährt ein Messwagen von der Rektie vorbei. Und da ja auch Notrufe abgesetzt werden über das GSM Netzwerk, ist es also ein Eingriff in eine kritische Infrastruktur und kein Spaß.
Das heißt auch vor allem, wenn man jetzt irgendwie ein GSM Netz offen hat und da geht der Nachbar mit seinem Handy rein und versucht da irgendwie einen Notruf abzusetzen, weil seine Bude brennt, wäre es ja nicht anzuraten, das zu tun.
Okay, es gibt also einige Sicherheitsverkehrungen, die man beachten müsste.
Dringend. Aber, wenn man die beachtet, ist es viel Spaß.
Das heißt, okay jetzt irgendwie auf Veranstaltungen, gerade wenn so technisch interessierte Leute zusammen sind, dass man da gerne dran rumbastelt, kann ich verstehen. Aber glaubt ihr, dass es irgendwie in absehbarer Zeit einen praktischen Nutzen hat, also im Sinne von, dass es irgendwie Sinn macht, sich sowas zuzulegen?
Naja, also es ist halt natürlich erstmal ein Forschungsprojekt. Man will halt diese Technologie verstehen, gucken, was man damit noch so anfangen kann. Und es ist halt so, dass diese Idee, dass das Funknetz jetzt nicht mehr zwingend nur von den großen Anbietern betrieben wird, die Kraft sind mehr oder weniger um sich. Es gibt halt zum Beispiel in Asien eine Menge Anbieter, die liefern mit ihren WLAN-Routern, also die du halt so an deinen DSL bekommst. Da ist dann halt auch plötzlich eine UMTS-Basisstation drin, damit die in den Hochhaus-Siedlungen und so, wo sie halt sonst Schwierigkeiten haben, so viel Deckung, also so viel Kanäle einfach bereitzustellen für so ein ganzes Hochhaus, dann benutzen die halt einfach den DSL-Anschluss zu Hause. Das hat in deinem WLAN-Router noch eine kleine Mobilfunkstation drin und die vermittelt wiederum die Anrufe ins Netz.
Das heißt, es ist auch gleichzeitig eine Lastverteilung für das große Netz. Also man hat viele kleine Zugangspunkte und somit verteilt sich natürlich auch die Last in general.
Genau, das Stichwort dafür ist Pico-Zellen und auch Nano-Zellen oder auch Femto-Zellen. Das sind halt so die Stichworte, nach denen man dann mal suchen kann, wenn einen das interessiert. Und de facto ist halt das, was man mit den eigenen Base-Tations macht, das ist auch so, man nimmt extrem geringe Sendelleistung, um halt möglichst keine Störung, um Netzwerk zu machen und achtet halt darauf, dass man halt das Netz nicht stört.
Wobei man sagen muss, die GSM-Basestation, die wir jetzt gerade haben, kann man nicht so mit Nano-Zellen vergleichen. Das ist dann so 50 Kilo schwer und wird scheiße.
Aber hat trotzdem halt nur 30 mW seine Leistung und es wird da geschaltet, ist so. Also Nano bezieht sich auf die Ausbreitung des Netzes. Auf die Ausbreitung des Netzes, die du machst, nicht auf die Zelle. Eine andere Variante, die auch noch sehr vielversprechend ist, ist das Projekt OpenBTS. Da geht es halt darum, auf der Basis einer freien Hardware, das sogenannten GNU Radio oder auch das USRP, Universal Software Radio Peripheral. Also kann man mal nach Google oder Wikipedia gucken.
Es ist nicht gut, wenn es keinen komplizierten Namen hat.
Es ist nur eine vierbuchstabige Abkürzung. Sie ist fast sprechend. Immerhin ein Vokal dabei. Und damit kann man halt auch, es ist halt de facto ein Stück Hardware, wo man in Software Funk machen kann. Das ist total toll, weil man kann, muss halt nicht mehr löten und da irgendwie komische Filter ranbauen und Oszilloskopen messen und diese ganzen schwierigen Dinge tun. Sondern man steckt einfach so ein Stück Hardware in den Computer und dann kommt da Funk rein und raus. So, das kann man sich einfach so vorstellen, so wie man Audio digitalisiert und rein und raus macht, kann man mit so einem USRP Funk rein und raus machen. Und damit kann man natürlich, wenn man die entsprechende Software baut, auch eine GSM-Funkstation machen. Das ist halt dieses Projekt OpenBTS, das ist halt ein bisschen weniger bekannt, als das, was Harald da macht, aber funktioniert mittlerweile auch. Damit wurde zum Beispiel auf dem Burning Man in Ameland, das ist halt so ein großes Hippie-Festival da irgendwo in der Wüste.
Wo alle nackt rumlaufen, Drogen nehmen und zum Schluss eine große Holzfüge verbrannt wird.
Genau, präzise Beschreibung. Die wollen natürlich da auch telefonieren. Und was die gemacht haben, da gibt es halt kein Mobiltelefonnetz, die haben halt einfach eins dahin gebaut. Für so eine Sache ist natürlich auch total super. Die haben halt mit diesem OpenBTS-System an vier Stellen auf dem Gelände halt eine so Bestie schon hingebaut und Zelte so mit irgendwie Kabel über den Acker geschmissen und haben halt Telefon für die Hippies da in der Wüste gemacht.
Telefone für Hippies gibt es schon oder kann es schon geben, weil man da rum basteln kann. Die umgedrehte Frage, wenn eine Technik so weit gekommen ist, dass man damit spielen kann, ist, wie sicher ist das eigentlich?
Ja, naja, also GSM ist halt nicht besonders sicher. Also man kann halt GSM schon abhören.
Ich glaube, es war in der Wikipedia, steht zu der Verschlüsselung bei GSM, was total toll ist. Da stand, dass ein sicherer Algorithmus vorgeschlagen wurde, aber dann doch der Entwurf der Franzosen genommen wurde. Also das mag einen Eindruck des Problems geben. Das ist sicher gemeint, aber nicht zu sicher. So dass die anderen nicht mithören können, aber wir.
Okay, das heißt beim Polizeifunk, wo wir die Sendung angefangen haben, ist es ja so, da kann jeder, also bei dem analogen Alten mithören, der sich einfach das passende Gerät holt, was die Frequenzen hören kann. Das ging ja wohl sogar mit so einem Mickey Mouse Radio, was irgendwann in der kleinen bunten Zeitung mit dabei lag. Wie schwierig ist es bei GSM?
Na ja, du brauchst halt so ein USAP, also so eine Software Radio. Du brauchst die entsprechende Software und du brauchst zum Dekrypten, also das bisschen Verschlüsselung, was da drauf ist. Zur entschlüsseln brauchen wir halt noch einen Stapel spezielle Chips und eine große Tabelle. Also man geht davon aus, dass man es halt so mit irgendwie einem Aufwand von vielleicht 5.000, 6.000 Euro in Nicht-Echtzeit mithören kann.
Nicht-Echtzeit heißt du würdest mitschneiden und dann hinterher sozusagen gucken, was da gelaufen ist.
Da gibt es halt ein Projekt, das heißt airprobe.org, wo diese Softwareentwicklung läuft. Es wird halt noch ein bisschen dauern. Da gab es ein paar Rückschläge, die halt irgendwie damit durchbedingt waren, dass natürlich Leute da draußen auch nicht unbedingt wollen, dass man ein GSM so einfach mithören kann.
Komisch.
Ja, überraschend. Aber am Ende würde es halt den Weg als Vergänglichen gehen, dieses GSM. Wir können halt davon ausgehen, die Bedarfträger, also der Staat kann immer mithören bei solchen Sachen. Aber wir können davon ausgehen, dass GSM über kurz oder lang auch in den Bereich des Amateurabhörens gehen wird. Genau den Weg, den auch ein anderes Verfahren, ein Digital-Funkverfahren gegangen ist, nämlich DECT. Da können wir nochmal drüber reden. DECT ist nämlich das Schnurrlust-Telefon. Habt ihr bestimmt auch alle zu Hause diese Schnurrlust-Telefone, mit denen man halt auch in der Badewanne telefonieren kann oder auf dem Balkon und so weiter und so fort. Da kann Andreas vielleicht noch ein bisschen was dazu erzählen zu dem DECT-Projekt.
Ja, das ist im Prinzip die selbe Situation wie bei dem Polizeifunk, aber nur schon vor zehn Jahren irgendwann wurde halt der analogisch Schnurrlust-Telefon-Service abgeschaltet und dann gab es DECT und dann hieß es DECT ist digital und deswegen nicht abhörbar. War so erstmal nicht richtig, weil irgendwie nur weil es digital ist, kann man es trotzdem dekodieren. Das geht auch mit so einem USRP sehr schön. Allerdings geht es auch noch besser mit einem anderen Projekt. Und es gab eine Gruppe von auch ZZ-Leuten aus Darmstadt, die sich da zusammengetan haben und die für eine DECT-Karte, die man in den Rechner stecken kann, eine Software entwickelt haben, um es mitzuschneiden und wo dann auch die Verschlüsselung mal angegangen wurde und Chips aufgeschliffen wurden, um sich die Verschlüsselung anzugucken. Und auch bei DECT ist die Verschlüsselung nicht allzu gut. Das sind 64 Bit und ich glaube sie sind noch nicht ganz fertig mit dem Krypto-Knacken-Projekt. Also es ist noch nicht so, dass man sich es runterlagen kann, auf den Knopf drücken, was man aber schon machen kann, ist es einzuschalten und zu gucken, wie viele Nachbarn denn so ein DECT-Gerät haben und wie viele davon tatsächlich nicht verschlüsselt telefonieren. Die gibt es nämlich auch.
Das wollte ich gerade sagen, im Anfang, als es rauskam, das war irgendwie zum letzten Chaos-Kongress, da war ja die Rede irgendwie von 50 Prozent, später hat mal jemand gesagt 80 Prozent senden unverschlüsselt.
Also eher 80 Prozent. Und die Leute wissen es halt nicht. Also auch häufig können auch die Hersteller es nicht mehr präzise beantworten, ob sie jetzt Verschlüsselung anhaben oder nicht. Man muss sich das auch mal so vorstellen, so ein Decktelefon kostet halt, also das billigste, was ich bisher gesehen habe, 14, 95. Und zwar ist das der Preis im Laden. Wenn man jetzt bedenkt, dass der Endpreis im Laden in der Regel so etwa bei zwei Drittel Aufpreis gegenüber dem Herstellerpreis in China liegt, dann heißt es, wenn sie da irgendwie 10 Cent sparen können bei der Herstellung, dann sparen sie die halt. So und genau das haben sie halt getan. Die haben halt einfach diese Krüpto-Funktionalitäten schlicht eingespart und gesagt, Herr Gott, wer soll das schon abhören? Was kann schon passieren? Und haben halt genau diese Verschlüsselung einfach eingespart. Und daraus resultiert halt, dass also diese, ja, diese Schnurrlusttelefone, die halt mal eben eingeführt wurden, damit man sie eben nicht abhören kann. Also früher gab es halt diese analogen Schnurrlusttelefone. Die konnte man sehr trivial abhören, also einfach mit einem normalen Funkempfänger. Und die gibt es immer noch längst nicht mehr so häufig. Und bedeckt war jetzt halt die Frage halt so, naja, es ist wesentlich digital, also sollte es halt irgendwie sicher sein. Und das ist nun mittlerweile halt auch vorbei. Also wenn halt dann die Verschlüsselung nicht an ist, dann kann man es halt abhören mit irgendeinem Gehöhe für so eine Einsteckkarte oder mit so einem Gnu Radio bzw. USRP. Und wenn die Verschlüsselung an ist, dann ist vielleicht noch ein Jahr oder zwei sicher, ob es halt auch diese Verschlüsselung gebrochen ist, weil die halt eben nicht besonders hochkarätig zu sein scheint, soweit ich es verstanden habe.
Das ist ja mit dem Abhören dieser Sachen ist ja so, es gibt irgendwie das Projekt heißt Detected Org. Detected, genau. Und diese Hardware, die dafür verwendet wird, das ist ja einfach eine Einsteckkarte für Laptops.
So PCMCA ist das. Also letztlich auf Ebay, damals wo das Projekt aus dem Boden gestampft wurde, für 30 Euro oder so kaufen, mittlerweile teurer geworden, so um die 200 Euro. Wobei hier nochmal der Disclaimer, die Software ist relativ einfach zu benutzen, die Karte auch. Ist genau das gleiche mit GSM. Wenn man seinen Nachbarn beim Telefonieren zuhört, ist das höchst höchst höchst strafbar.
Aber es geht halt sehr einfach. Geht das nur dieser einen bestimmten Hardware, die ja irgendwie veraltet ist und deswegen jetzt auch so teuer, weil sie einfach nicht mehr produziert wird? Oder wird da auch an weiteren Dingen gearbeitet?
Es gibt da auch diese USRP-Lösung, also die komplette Softwarelösung. Das USRP ist so, dass er in Anführungszeichen Wunderteil mit dem man alles empfangen kann. Eierlegende Wollmilch.
Schweizer Taschenmesser.
Vom Kurzwellenfunk über analog 70 cm. Ich glaube sowas wie 700 Euro. Kennten wir es denn davon ab, welche Frontend-Module man reinsteckt, also auf welchen Frequenzen man zuhören möchte?
Das heißt aber, wir sind noch nicht bei einem Level wie WEP, WLAN-Verschlüsselung, wo man sich einfach mal hinsetzt und das macht, wenn man Bock drauf hat. Sondern es ist schon noch mit Aufwand verbunden, das zu machen. Zumindest einem kleinen Finanziellen.
Einem kleinen Finanziellen.
Kleiner Finanzieller.
Es ist aber andererseits so, dass wenn man zum Beispiel ein mittelständisches Unternehmen ist oder eine Anwaltskanzlei, dass man dann eigentlich besser nicht mehr über Deck telefonieren sollte.
Man ist sich absolut sicher, dass die Verschlüsselung an ist.
Selbst da würde ich nicht drauf tippen, je nachdem was man so für Kunden hat.
Genau, wenn man halt irgendwie Kunden hat, die ein bisschen größeres Budget haben, bzw. die nicht so sehr Freunde von Kunden, die man hat, die ein großes Budget haben, dann empfiehlt es sich auch nicht. Also im Wesentlichen kann man sagen, diese Schnurrlostechnologien sind momentan nicht zu empfehlen. Also auch ein anderes Ding sind zum Beispiel drahtlose Keyboards, das ist auch sehr beliebt. Schnurrlostestaturen, die sind halt auch abhörbar. Die kann man halt auch mitschneiden.
Jetzt ohne Probleme oder auch mit?
Ja, ohne Probleme.
Das Schönste was ich jetzt gehört habe ist, wo wir gerade dabei sind, haben Wissenschaftler aus Stuttgart rausgefunden, dass man Nadeldrucker abhören kann?
Und zwar akustisch. Akustisch, genau. Ja, das war schon eine Weile bekannt, dass das funktioniert. Die haben es jetzt noch mal ein bisschen schöner ausgeführt. Und es hat natürlich auch Implikationen für ein anderes, unser Lieblingsthema, nämlich die Wahlcomputer. Weil da natürlich der Hersteller dieser NEDAP-Wahlcomputer möchte gerne da so eine Nadeldrucker nachrüsten. Er hat wohl Grüne gewählt.
Ich meine, wenn man damit Musik machen kann, dann...
Also das fängt völlig vom Thema ab, aber was solls, ist ja eh gleich vorbei. Der Nachteil bei den Wahlcomputern war, dass man nicht nachweisen kann, was da drin passiert. Deswegen sollte ein sogenannter Paper Trail eingeführt werden. Also die sollten ein Zettelchen ausdrucken, wo drauf steht, was derjenige gewählt hat, was derjenige dann in die Hand kriegen kann. Und das soll dann per Nadeldrucker gemacht werden.
Genau, das ist halt so einer der Pläne, die da momentan kursieren. Aber das ist halt ziemlich ja Unsinn. Und wir gehen mal davon aus, dass es auch irgendwann wieder beerdigt werden wird. Wenn nicht, müssen wir es halt nochmal zeigen, dass es kaputt ist.
Das hat ja schon mal ganz gut geklappt.
Das machen wir gerne.
Wie, haben wir beim Digitalfunk jetzt noch irgendwas vergessen? Also ich fürchte mich eigentlich diese Frage zu stellen, weil wir noch wenige Minuten haben.
Wir haben glaube ich irgendwie nicht geredet über digitalen Kurzwellenfunk. Wir haben nicht geredet über DVB. Doch, DVB-T haben wir mal.
Da hatte ich doch am Anfang die Frage, ob es da so Basteleien gibt, wie man deinen Empfang verbessern kann?
Antennen, also bessere Antenne, so wie früher.
Also so ein bisschen mit dem Standort spielen, irgendwie gucken, dass man vielleicht eine Aktivantenne benutzt, mit einem besseren Gewinn dann auch und ans Fenster, solche Sachen.
Das wollte ich fragen. Ich hab es ein paar Mal schon probiert, diese ganzen USB-Sticks, die man sich da in den Rechner steckt, die haben immer einen grottigen Empfang. Und dann liest man im Kleingedruckten des Geräts, ja es könnte sein, dass man sich eine Aktivantenne dazukaufen muss. Das ist eigentlich eher noch Standard, oder?
Ich glaube schon. Also was dieses Digitalfernsehen eingeführt hat, das muss man vielleicht mal erzählen für all die Leute, die Panik vor Elektrosmog haben. Früher so ein Fernsehsender, der hat gerne mal mit 1 Kilowatt gesendet. Und so ein moderner Digitalfernsehsender, der sendet dann mit sowas wie 50 bis 100 Watt. Das heißt, allein dadurch, dass das analoge Fernsehen in Deutschland abgeschaltet wurde, ist die Elektrosmog Belastung auf den Viertel zurückgegangen.
Aber die Pulse!
Was?
Pulse?
Genau, digital, also digital pulsiert doch immer so. Und das ist natürlich ganz schlecht.
So, dann würde ich vorschlagen, wir gucken jetzt noch mal, wie viele Unterzeichner es gibt. Im Chat hieß es dann auch so, das ist doch gar nicht die offizielle Zahl. Aber es ist halt die einzige, die ich habe, die von der Seite.
Ich sag nochmal ein tolles Wort, was hier auf dem Zettel steht, was wir nicht mehr erklären werden. Quadratur Amplituden Modulation.
Okay, wenn wir schon so weit sind, ja, dann machen wir doch das hier.
Das ist einfach, das ist fünf Tonnen, da gibt es einfach irgendwie.
Ja, das wird verwendet, um sozusagen auf dem aktuellen Bossfunk Steuerinformationen zu übertragen. Also zum Beispiel Einsatzfahrzeug teilt Leitstelle mit, dass es jetzt gerade mit den Einsatz übernommen hat zum Beispiel.
Ist dieses Signal schon ein Code für ein bestimmtes Ereignis?
Dieses Signal ist schon vorher festgelegt, ein Code für ein bestimmtes Ereignis meistens. Da gibt es irgendwie bei den meist umgerüsteten Analogfunk in den Polizeiautos dann auf dem Handhörerknöpfchen, womit man dann auswählen kann, irgendwie einen Einsatzleiter habe, Einsatz übernommen.
Aber es ist doch so, wie ich heute über euch gelernt habe, dass Analogfunk der Funk ist, wo man quasi einfach mitmachen kann, wenn man nur die richtige Frequenz erwischt.
Das ist durchaus richtig.
Das heißt, wenn man sich so eine Signale abfängt und dann mal schön in das Netz, also in den Ether pustet.
Dann tut man illegale Dinge.
Ja, deutlich illegale Dinge. Man muss sagen, wir werden deutlich weniger Spaß haben mit dem Zuhören am nächsten 1. Mai, aber vielleicht ist es doch besser, dass sie auf digital umsteigen.
Ja, also hier wird gerade noch angemerkt, die 5-Ton-Folgen sind tatsächlich zum Alarmieren, also um halt z.B. Sirenen auszulösen, ähnliche Dinge. Die Status-Meldung ist der FMS Telegram, das Funk-Meldesystem. Das ist halt so ein Prrrz, das halt vor dem Funk-Spruch und wenn man dieses Prrrz dekodiert bekommt, dann kriegt er eine Kiste Mate.
Eine Kiste, wow. Apropos dekodiert, es gab ja vorhin eine Morse-Folge zu hören. Ich habe noch per Chat den Hinweis bekommen, Chaosradio ist zu 50% richtig, würde ich sagen.
Genau.
Wollen wir es auflösen, weil jetzt ist die Sendung gleich vorbei.
Kriegt ihr eine halbe Mate?
Eine halbe ausgetrunken.
Okay, der zweite Tipp wäre gewesen, Chaosradio Digitalfunk.
Ja, das ist korrekt.
Damit herzlichen Glückwunsch an Ravox, der glaube ich entweder selber geraten oder im Chat gut abgeguckt hat.
Der kriegt von mir auch eine volle Mate.
Einzulösen nächsten Donnerstag in den Clubräumen des Chaos Computer Club Berlin.
Das war es Chaos Radio für heute. Es waren nicht viele Leute dabei, aber wir konnten viel lernen über Digitalfunk. Nächsten Monat um diese Zeit erwartet euch wie gewohnt der Kollege Jakob Kranz und neue Gäste vom Chaos Computer Club. Ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Abend. Vielen Dank Andreas, Björn und Frank, dass ihr hier wart. Famous Last Words. Und spielt schön am Gerät. Und zum Abschluss gibt es noch ein Song aus dem Netz, den es einfach da frei runter zu laden gibt und zwar von Trackey Birthday. Website. Ein sehr schönes Beispiel wie Nerdcore. Ach, das vergessen. Und als nächstes nach dem Nerdcore kommen Smith & Smart und irgendwie 100.000 andere Leute in Studio, machen euch einen Nightflight, der wirklich cool wird. Also er muss wirklich cool werden, weil die Jungs machen am 29.5. eine Konichi Bar Bitches Party. Ich hab vergessen wo, aber Maxwell, der vorm Studio steht und total böse guckt, wird euch das bestimmt gleich noch 5000 mal sagen. Auf jeden Fall jetzt im Casio Paya hör ich da gerade. Konichi Bar Bitches Party mit Casio Paya, in der Casio Paya am 29.5. mit den Leuten, die gleich hier ins Radio kommen. Jetzt geh ich aber wirklich genug geredet.
Vorsicht vor den Pulsen.
Ruhe im Saal oder ich lass den Saal räumen. Angeklagter, hier wird vorgeworfen, Musik illegal aus dem Internet heruntergeladen zu haben. Was sagen Sie dazu?
Ich hab sie doch gleich wieder hochgeladen. Und das wird man.